thank you what do you Archer do you
appreciate the advantages of the
tactical turtleneck
maybe clearly we've worn the same
clothes like Lada I was winning at first
realise the tactical advantages of a
turtleneck after the fight back I got
this was a little heavier so it's
actually it's hanging off me a bit but
oh that's okay look ridiculous in the no
matter wha assisted anyone looks
ridiculous indeed tactical turtleneck
even though that would be going against
the definition of it but ah
danger zone yes so clearly Archer has a
lot to do with good burger I wish it
make it so much easier thinking Oh
sweetie be like the Bob's burger
crossover ha ha ha
Archer puss good burger oh my god I'd be
amazing about burger did like and what
is your deal are you like stone 24/7 you
pause burger gonna goods are things
which good burger that'd be amazing oh
my god ah good a good burger I'm with a
good burger can I take your order why do
I have to say that it's for taking wood
I don't laugh oh my god
uh all right so let's this one's gonna
be mostly on you I'm not sure I have
much to say about mine I remember
because again this was what do you say
except it's I I can talk about how this
was kind of like just one of many like
we moved from like probably our favorite
place we ever lived we used to live in
Seattle and it was just like the place
of childhood dreams for us is the
perfect spot then we moved to Rhode
Island I'll tell you it is it is middle
fucking earth it is like it's like so
beautiful like mountains and there's
like trolls that hill there's actually a
troll under a bridge in the city there
they built a statue to troll but but
then we moved to Rhode Island which if
you're an adult I can see enjoying it
for a kid it's a fucking nightmare
because there's nothing to do and
everybody's miserable and on top of that
this is when movies began to suck this
was the beginning of like that Dark Age
of movies and good burger was one of the
first movies I saw an ad for when we
moved there and I just always assumed
Sanibel yeah I first obviously thought
it was more like 2000 tours oh no no no
no no no
then this came off of um all that you
know a me oh oh oh yeah okay you
badmouth all that I'll pay him out
Cooper cuz I did mine all that at lunch
this is Justin I didn't mind all that
battle you know what it was meant for
kids I guess it was in living color for
kids yeah yeah everyone was I moved
everything that made it live in color
fine but it was for kids
yeah oh I I didn't mind all that but I
get for a kid's sketch show it's along
the lines of life you can't do that
television or something it's like you
know it it's fine um and even for that
sketch that kids voice is funny you know
if it welcome to good burger what you
can't do that on television way more it
was also more surreal it was also more
mascot what kids and torture chambers
and getting shot by firing squads of red
and dysfunctional families that bar
fronting this diner with the burgers
with the greens yeah job and everything
um but I can't retaining really son the
80s were gritty is fuck um but yeah but
this was a spinoff of that show and I
did mind the show but clearly it's like
you can't make a movie out one well it
it is ironic because what was
essentially Nickelodeon's children's
version of SNL Bay's I'm a badass
basically did the same mistake SNL fit
which is oh well we have a sketch that
lasted ten minutes and some people left
let's make a movie but like let's take
those unfunny jokes and make them so
that like really little kids could get
give me a good shake okay uh uh uh uh I
just saw I never got hurt I remember I
was reading this was one where I liked
reading the reviews for the movie
because people were just trying so I God
gave us Rotten Tomatoes ya know this is
one we're just all the critics were
trying to be so humble with the fact
that this is a kid's film I remember
being a kid and liking stupid stuff and
this is naive and innocent but it is
stupid it is so stupid
one was just like this guy was he just
starts off with you know you list one
the joke it's like guy walks into a
restaurant and tells the owner to watch
his but he curiously turns around
looking at his butt spinning he does
this for about a minute
that's as funny is against folks
it's like that is the crowning
achievement joke of this movement
blacked out most of this movie oh you're
gonna see Moshe kill O'Neill I know you
remember that all I remember is a said
Abe Vigoda that's all I remember just
didn't sing there just Oh nobody yeah I
just remember looking like you said
saddle yeah that's all I remember from
good burger we I think we reviewed it
just at the point we're making from a
pagoda it was like a big thing for Conan
and it's like oh hey sit this Wookiee
let's let's ride that tray so we just
made fun of a pagoda cuz what's evil
gonna get a visa hasn't good sense a
humor oh the only thing I think that
made me let know there's two things that
maybe laugh and they're strangely enough
at the very end of the movie what is it
every one of them was from Sinbad's uh
when the burger Falls my car we can
laugh at Sinbad
early every four hundred jokes
haha there's a good ship it's not like a
plant that blooms every forty years it's
like the court yes that will get his
Lobby joke they got this flower at the
Chicago Botanical Gardens yeah blooms
like once every 80 years and smells like
shit well I'm not gonna say the smell
like cher part I'm sure he has great
hygiene um but the ones that every 80
years but oh yeah no I got nothing this
man ever do to it yeah well yeah so me
you do him Oh jingle all the way
okay you know he we probably got a
couple years left still for jingle away
but after a couple years we should lay
off so I say you stand I've been stayin
those funny and everything I got nobody
gets in bed by and again there was the
here one funny yell when the burger
falls on his guy just destitution of why
but they just thought I forgot what and
which and it cuts away it was like a
perfect edit from a perfectly delivered
line and then I love it when he wants to
go in business with him or something
like that the two kids and then he's
like I don't know if I can I just goes
it's because of black it's like that's
really funny especially for kids felt
that very very so we've kind of know
three laughs for an hour and a half I
counted two
people iou around the throat Sinbad said
two steps removed from pixels Oh
maybe pixels was worse than I remember
gives mime calculating it in my head up
my ass about how many times I'll have
but um not as well as Phil's where it's
like I kind of think like I remember
they did like I think it to us it's like
what Saved by the Bell did like their
big finishing TV movie where they go to
Vegas I like the people you think we get
married get married and stuff like that
baby like the bill the new bed yeah
glass thank you oh my dog they didn't
like this home I wouldn't kill though
they God all out of that and what
happens in Vegas stays in Vegas and then
it's like one of screeches actual porno
video I was gonna say I which doesn't
Diamond stated Vegas action baby so to
think he is good could be um but yeah
it's one of those things where it's like
it was kinda like and they had this TV
movie and then it's like okay here's our
big you know whatever goodbye finale
whatever it's still gonna suck but here
it is for you and that's kind of a
feeling with good burger it's like it
still sucks
but if you like it if you have the
nostalgia value it's like fair enough
it's just one of those stupid things but
ya know it's - I heard him I know I'm
more of a nice kid so a good chunk of
the 90s I was already either in junior
high or high school hmm so this is well
past my age range so if you were a 90's
kid if you were like if you topped out
about maybe 12 years old by the time the
90s ended um remanding this was this
something that you were like I need this
good burger sister if my life will not
be complete without this good burger
movie give me my good burger I'm just
curious because I think well no here's
the thing
Ellie I don't know I'm thinking if I was
a little kid you know uh and I grew up
with all that I saw there was a movie on
that character with the funny voice who
has a lot of energy the big smile and uh
you know it's like I if I was a double
kid I'd be like you know yeah it might
be fun I see it and be like I just watch
nothing you know and
our parents would have german-us past a
place that had caught on fire and said
oh look the cinema burned down yep
I can't wait till come son like good
parent shit - can we talk comes on VHS
Oh our VCR just exploded
oh sorry oh we went to every video store
it's not there
well we can rent it out sorry digital
download all the Internet's broke back
man just blew up you can ever go on the
Internet Bali enough we have the earth I
say I think we're the early stages oh
it's uh we have AOL and you don't
nothing works on that so I already got
proven uh midnight yeah there would have
been a well um but yeah it's uh I don't
know it's hard for me to be like angry
at it cuz it so was not my thing and
it's so obviously for you know a younger
audience address and but I mean it is
phenomenally lazy writing but it's for I
will say this watching the kids in this
movie maybe this is kind of what pull
through like all that and stuff is that
despite the bed right it just the
downright lazy writing uh the kids are
really trying I never felt like the kids
were half-assing it like you get to home
alone to and you watch Macaulay Culkin's
like he's clearly coasting you know he's
just like yeah I'm Astana I don't have
to try it uh but it's like these days
the door Bell's gonna ring you're gonna
talk if I go away I loved him before
home away - he's just gonna like using
before hohoho - he's not even saying
he's just gonna punch you in the face
and walk away
I probably have it coming no and I he
can be a good actor now I don't know
just you're a little kid they'll have to
be as a little kid app until I get it
was a little kid you just be like I
don't to try anymore but that's why I
like that's why the okay I'll share this
movie ya know I think it's worth to try
the kids were trying but it's the way
kids try in a school play written by an
adult who has no idea how really
terrible of a writer there hmm
like trying to write like you ever Sam
one of those awful school plays like I
begged in some of ya and you know and
the directors like so full of themselves
like it's gonna be so mazes it now
you're just doing just right and the
like and it's shit it's like and it's
men and it's like seriously a
five-year-old level but the kids are
trying
hmm
it still doesn't make it easy to sit
through yeah and I think it's one of
those things - I think the writers kind
of thing like oh it's it's for kids so
we have to dumb down the jokes
you see and that's the thing I on the
dead that's the problem is I think the
kids were trying a lot harder than the
Reds and the adults worried yeah yeah um
and I think that is something where's
the difference like I you can't do that
on television was something aimed at our
age at the time but I felt like the
adults writing it hit a sick or more
sardonic sense of humor sty nearly four
kids love life for kids but they're just
like all right bitch yeah let's have
some let's have some fun with this yeah
like where is where as good burger and
all that I always felt like it was just
let's play this safe you know what it is
is hey let's do that T is what the 90s
was all about life yeah you're very
plague coming out of the 80s like we're
playing it safe yeah um I think you're
right that's private start of the big PC
thing the political correct so V we
can't have violence and cartoons and
shows and stuff like that so you're
right I think it started to go really
really safe and now we're in kind of
like this again because of the internet
the this extreme on both sides the
extreme like hate Phil we're gonna
offend everybody and and fuck you all
and stuff and then the extreme were you
know very sensitive and don't offend
anybody into NHS these two extremes
going me I just like is it funny yeah no
but we are getting some good stuff I
mean to be fair um because there are
people that can do both very good they
can offend very well and they can be
very sensitive very well awesome can do
both at the same time uh and it is fine
too because I think I forgive I'm very
sensitive to offending people yes
assistan I offend people I'm very
sensitive to it
yes and I enjoy doing it I can feel
they're very sensitive but when I'm free
also taught if I was talking about this
in a V log before but it when i watch i
watch the gravity falls episode and then
they hail like a few uh this was a
Tucanos with my wife and we're just like
sleep the TV on who no no what does he
gravity falls anyway leave a TV it is a
let's just leave it on i
remember what I watched but it was like
some sort of kids sitcom or something
like that and just watching it it's like
it's not nice laughing funny but it's
clear they were putting so much more
effort into it than any kids sitcom they
put out when we were younger
hi hi effort I have flipped through and
landed on Nick or Disney or something
it's done the same way because I'm just
like I I'm very curious what the hell
kids are watching so land on something
and yeah it is the same thing it's like
this is clearly not meant for me I
clearly don't find it really
entertaining but I'm like this is still
steps ahead of what I got like 20 years
ago yeah there's something where it's a
you can still ride kids aren't tainment
a teenage entertainment and tween
entertainment and stuff like that not be
like oh well they're tweens their kids
so we can write fucking anything and
they'll go for it instead no and we're
still going to try rapid Ephrem we're
gonna try and develop their sense of
humor at that appropriate and there was
and there was a difference because like
we did it you can't do that on
television but sometimes like kids
programming in the 80s like versus the
90s it if you had a sitcom that was kind
of meant also for kids it was a sitcom
that kind of ran in primetime it wasn't
like you had it at work like a yeah dick
family Adar's his children like we do
now with Cartoon Network and Disney and
and Nick there were no kids sitcoms on
the Disney Channel in the 80s it was all
reruns of Disney shit yeah like from the
70s in the 50s yeah Mickey Mouse
Clubhouse the closest to our sick we had
the canoe Mickey Mouse oh that's right
where Mickey had like the polo shirt or
whatever let me tell you let me tell you
that can't you why oh us see Mickey
Mouse and they're doing the thing where
they're jumping up in the air like Oh
Ivan back down against the green screen
gather round children let me tell you a
scary story The New Mickey Mouse Club
that ran back when we were kids was so
bad that I ended up just watching the
old Mickey Mouse because at least I was
promised a fucking cartoon somewhere in
the middle of it and generally they were
Donald Duck and they were pretty
freaking hilarious yes more Chip and
Dale I do remember that being really bad
actually that the new Mickey Mouse Club
if I sir forgot about it I was like no I
remember really tried to modern I can't
forget II tried to make
like lady Di's early night I think those
are we this kind of Saved by the Bell
yeah - it was out of late 80s early and
I just kind of pink and yeah yeah like
the old Mickey Mouse Club is corny but
it's like they're tap dancing they're
singing they're doing all this cool
stuff and the new one it's like he's
just where our ever Crombie shirts you
know which aren't round yet but that's
what these are we're just gonna sit
we're gonna chat or it could be like
wool it's like that was it if everybody
wissy yeah and throwing a pop song or
something um but so the grass is always
greener is our point we did have some
things every way grittier in the 80s but
but there's much better stuff now -
there's much more so now I think we can
all agree just the 90s just a cultural
wasteland getting I'm kidding don't kill
me it looks kind of where we were going
for a while we turn this around I sort
of say the mid to late 90s slash kind of
early 2000s and then we got good again I
always argue actually the early 90s when
you like watching it now 20-something
years later like as an adult I'm like
when I see old things from nearly 90s
I'm like holy shit it's still the 80s
the 80s yeah
Danny's really didn't die for me - about
1993 most decades are like the last like
yeah there was like this kind of holder
just like the 90s - because it continues
till about Oh - maybe so with with good
burger if you're a part of that you have
the nostalgia you like it I didn't
totally understand I'm not gonna be like
you freak you more I totally get it
good from ya by a number of doctors you
can do but I mean don't don't act like
it's good you can like some things in it
like I said you can like the energy from
the kids you can like some of the colors
and say you're it's a time capsule of
the 90s Bharath a don't try to hawk it
off it's like no no you know what like
we knew how to make good films back then
we made fucking good burger it's like no
it's fucking stupid a say in the world
who I don't tempt them Frodo really I I
think it's kind of I'm glad I'm ignorant
sometimes of some of the things I think
most people know it's bad but they're
counting on you don't to be that mean
it's kind of like I do
that's a job yeah they have our job
watch it otherwise but no it's important
to know here's the thing
okay not especially good their thing
there too there are three things that I
grew up with one word legitimately good
shows or movies that were legitimately
great and meant for kids are meant for
all ages and I still enjoy them now the
second are things that were meant only
for kids that as an adult I may not
watch it as much or if I do watch it as
an adult i watch it only for nostalgia
but I can say you know what this was
aimed for eight-year-olds and under and
it was good it was fine you were eight
years old and then there are things that
are aimed at kids and work if you're a
kid but even as a grown adult you have
to admit was just shit yeah it's like
this was aimed at kids but even shit by
aimed at kids standards yeah so it that
is that is you have got something at apt
on a fad or something that was popular
at the time or maybe even created it and
exposed it and didn't try that harder
trying to tap more into what's popular
about as opposed to what's good about it
and I didn't watch usually don't hold
things from the 80s that I saw and MK
completely aware of it that was like
this is shit this was garbage they
literally threw at us and we needed hook
line and sinker but it puts me in a
nostalgic place and I enjoy it and it's
fine I don't claim it's good though like
there's live at things
aim for children there are legitimately
like good and bad things and like
there's some that I'm just like yeah I
still like it but I still know it's crap
yeah I think it's important to know that
this thing's Tiffany your good burger is
like the Citizen Kane of kids new wife a
guy I wait tonight somebody did or was
that mister cranky or whatever that
review like he gave it like this guy
reviews Oh mr. cranky whatever
he might be still be around we just have
gone to the site um but yeah I don't I
don't think that sites been updating a
long time I I don't know I haven't gone
that was some funny shit that was he
reviewed everything like he hated
everything that he watched very much II
and you able to buy bombs but then like
a 1.com was the best and that I like for
bombs has really been dynamited my
favorite was cuz I've used this on all
the time dynamite was proof that Jesus
died in vain
yeah that's where I got that line but
then but then with like good burger he
put a smiley face I think it just broke
him he was just like this magical
wonderful delightful yeah just talked
about how beautiful when a pagoda says
such beautiful gut-wrenching lines like
I broke my ass it will bring a tear to
your eye
any review they want we call that mr.
happy yeah Oh big inside gets it was
pretty funny it's kind like our surf
ninjas review where we just said
everything it was like so bad that we
actually gave it a good review tell you
something cuz a lot of times kids films
will get a pass enough they'll get the
the two stars the good burger was really
fucking revile at the time I remember
critics were merciless and there was a
reason it's not any good and if you saw
it when you were five you're like I
enjoyed and brings back memories here a
good burger it's awesome cut for you
good for you just don't tell me it's a
good movie and enjoy all the hell you so
yeah there it is a still stupid movie
but if that's your poison more power to
you uh I'm gonna go watch the Ralph
Bakshi lor the rains cuz that's my
poison I know it I know it's not good
but I love it um and I'm just gonna
drink wild turkey but that's my pleasure
boy is it I'm sure yours is much more
healthy than mine oh let's both agree
they're both more healthy than good
burger they and they both ironically
kill the liver we're not sure of the
match gay film does that it finds a way
uh so that's about it we'll see you in
the next one later bye
take your order go